john luster 12th career start against
the phillies he's ready we are right on
time at 705 and here we go
first pitch ryan zimmerman backhand pick
lester covers
nice start on the defensive side yeah
zimmer's ready it's good to see him back
in the lineup starting
have that gold glove
move from one corner to the next hey you
better be ready to play on the first
pitch of a major league ball the ball
will always find you as well you know
especially with the lineup changes today
look for all the guys who haven't played
much look for the ball to find them
making some noise early i think the
nantz fans are a little restless they
want to see harper retired and get this
lineup going
and there's a good start to the evening
harper frozen
on 88. so a good play by zimmerman a
pop-up and a strikeout and john lester
off to a good start tonight zach wheeler
making his eighth start in the year
fastball 96-100 second hardest fastball
in the big leagues to jacob degrom four
seamer has been really effective both
righty and lefties
one and two
tapper that stays fair it's a hit it's
coming back fair that's fair and it was
touched by boehm in fair territory one
soda hits one about 60 feet for a single
yeah definitely a mistake by the young
infielder there you know you'd like to
see that ball roll if your exact wheeler
a little bit further down the line to
see what it's going to do because you
have no chance to throw a monster one
out in this case right here and actually
i remember too when i played here back
in nine and ten with our lead off guys
we would work on that try to get this
ball down the line here use a little
home advantage if you know what i mean
on circulating that line to make sure
that ball would come back in fair
territory hoskins to get into the
batters box here as we start the second
inning
my drive out to left field there's a
base hit and rhys hoskins aboard lead
off single here in the second here is
andrew knapp andrew has a chance again
tom ground ball toward the hole into
left field at base hit rounding third
heading for home is hoskins no throw by
schwarber andrew knapp comes through
with an rbi single the phillies are on
top one nothing
he said last night that he feels like
he's swinging the bat better than his
numbers dictate
yeah this is beautiful i mean castro and
turner both make diving ever try to keep
it in the infield and keep reeks from
scoring but they couldn't do it you see
it just out of the reach of castro and
then just out of the reach of trey
turner and there's one away one two
look at that curveball beauty first
strikeout it's just so hard when you
have to start so early to try to catch
up to high velocity to stay back and hit
something that slow well now john lester
had a strike three call right down the
chute 97 miles an hour no runs one hit
and one man left onto the third fills up
one nothing and here's andrew stevenson
two and two swing it a miss slider
strikeout number three for wheeler and
trey turner is the hitter three and two
and a call strike three on the inside
corner four strikeouts for wheeler two
in the second two here in the third and
the nationals go down in order to out
top of the fifth leicester up to 80
pitches
harper reaching out and he's got a base
hit they're waving the runner
schwarber's throw coming home
targets and it's not even close at the
plate
kyle schwarber throws out oh
herrera to keep it a one-run game a huge
play right there for the nationals
absolutely what a strong throw philly's
looking replay but i don't think he ever
got near getting to the plate schwarber
let it loose one time catcher coming up
and herrera got the tag right in the
face
from avila here's bowm who has walked
and struck out it'd be nice for john to
give this quality start tonight
gonna miss
he kind of fooled the rookie or the
second year guy
in his first full big league season with
that up and for john lester his fourth k
in the night boom twice yeah you can
hear boom's frustration missing that
elevated change up here's nick maton a
24 year old shortstop from chatham
illinois high fly ball over his head out
to schwarber who drifts into foul ground
to make the grab
getting to know the ballpark better and
better every night tune out
sometimes it's tough in these little
areas as you get close to the fans i
know the netting will protect you but in
the back of your mind as an outfielder
you're worried about running and
crashing into the wall and banging your
knee but boom we got it in quickly good
play and junetna runner going in this
one out to schwarber who's playing about
130 feet off the left field line and he
puts it away more than quality from john
lester tonight four strikeouts three
walks one run in six innings all right
here we go bottom six ryan zimmerman so
good at using the entire ballpark based
on what he's getting
kind of like that
deep left center
one hopper off the wall
ryan zimmerman to the pull side and the
tang runs aboard in the sixth
wheeler hung that slider and then did
not miss it good swing here to get us
going so really really been feeling that
slider so far but this one's belt high
and zim with a great line drive swing
and look how he just sees the ball so
well
this is a rock in the gap
and bob to your point about how zim
likes to spray the ball right field or
lupo herrera what's shifted into the
right center field gap he's in with a
great swing let's go boys now we have
man in scoring position with less than
two outs stalin castro's coming up and i
think starlin has rbi on his mind
looking for his 15th run better than and
he wants to seal the deal quickly this
game is tight got ryan on got him over
got him in his 405th career double
leads to the tying run here in the sixth
inning exactly what we need stalin
castro sticking to his plan being
aggressive early
wheeler just left this fastball out over
the middle of the plate and starlin
castro being the great fastball hitter
that he is did not miss it with a
scorcher three for three tonight one out
avila the hitter
oh they'll see if they can get him ahead
get up
high fly ball lots of carry by avila
where
they didn't catch it it's on the ground
now it rolls around by the scoreboard
all the way around is castro the dads
have taken the lead
that ball has to be caught by somebody
and neither of the phillies got to it
well bryce and oduba were looking at one
another as the ball was in the air
the great hustle by avila to get on
third here
i think everybody in the ballpark
assumed this was an out but as you watch
avila i'm sorry double and bryce get
closer whether bryce is checking out
what i like to call that is a no catch
and then a tackle
good for by bryce laying him out
well castro was going halfway and then
he had a long way to go
the phillies not only missed the ball
they failed to pick it up cleanly which
would have kept the runners at second
and third yeah castro did a good job
there because you have to hang out you
assume it's going to be caught and then
he got on this horse and the villa
showing us those wheels well now odubal
herrera who is one for threes oh on the
count
and a high fly ball out to right center
field going back on it is roll plays
it's gone he tied it up and he knew it
the fat flip as soon as the ball left
his back
it's a 2-2 game here in the top of the
ninth inning
second home run
on this trip for herrera
brad hand stays in the ball game and
he'll face bryce harper nobody out top
of the 10th hitting
opposite way for harper he flares it to
left field it's in for a base hit
mccutchen stops at third they're not
gonna test schwarber's arm again
harper has three hits tonight the
phillies have first and third with
nobody out here in the top of the tenth
inning a pitching change finnegan is
coming in gotta trust the fact that one
of these next two guys can drive in a
run the ball's in one strike to hoskins
and he whacks that one into left field
at base center run is in harper to
second he'll stop there
rbi single it's 3-2 phillies
20 rbis now for hoskins he'll now keep
the line moving they taught his own for
two
now it's pulled into right field of base
center runnell score it's an rbi signal
from aton
and the phillies
increased their lead it's four to two
and the rookie comes through again yeah
that's big with a runner starting on
second base to get that extra run
hit by
mayton look look at how short just short
compact swing here's andrew knapp he's
one for four with an rbi tonight
and a live drive base hit it to center
field another rental score rbi single
for knapp his second rbi of the night
5-2 phillies
listen to the crowd in the background
like a home game but then he just hones
it in two balls and two strikes throw a
fastball away and see what happens two
and two the pitch
swing and a miss he got him and the
phillies
have won a road series
of three games or more for the first
time since september of 2019.